[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
public officials and the ex-cops
involved with the police killing of
briana taylor
seek to throw her boyfriend's lawsuit
against them out of court
a father and son charged in the ahmad
aubry case ask a judge to set
bail do gregory and travis mcmichael
pose a flight risk
is a mental health diagnosis enough to
take the death penalty off the table
for a former pro baseball player
convicted of triple homicide
also been you know engaging in violent
acts with
uh teammates and his family members and
the discovery of prosecutors racist
emails leads to a woman's exoneration
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to long crime daily
everybody i'm erin keller along with
brian buckmeyer and terry austin a
hearing in a civil suit against a former
louisville police officer filed by the
boyfriend of briana taylor
kenneth walker is suing detective brett
hankinson and others claiming violations
of kentucky's stand your ground law
walker says he was illegally detained
and charged after he used his
legal firearm to fight back who he
thought were intruders but
who turned out to be hankinson and
plainclothes officers walker religious
assault battery false arrest and
imprisonment
malicious prosecution abuse of process
negligence and other claims
a representative from the attorney
general's office said walker failed to
state a claim
didn't suffer legally recognized
injuries and had no standing to sue
there are three principles to standing
and that is injury causation and
redressability and
the plaintiff it is the plaintiff's
burden to demonstrate each of those
and here they they plainly cannot mr
walker cannot
prove that he has any injury in fact uh
that is
uh traceable or caused by the attorney
general
uh that the
traceability or causation is for the
reasons i outlined above and that's
the attorney general's statutory
authority in matters like this which
which is not it's more secondary to when
he's requested to step in
that has not occurred here the attorney
general has made clear he's not
investigating mr walker
and has no authority to prosecute mr
walker especially where mr wine
has retained that portion of the
investigation and potential prosecution
it's a mere hypothetical that he is
posing here
it is it is the case perhaps that he may
not be indicted
at all an attorney for the local
prosecutor made similar arguments and
said
that office was doing the correct thing
brian listen to this
tom has promised to take the appropriate
action in this case
just as he has in every case his
decision as to whether that means to
seek indictment
or to make efforts to amend the
dismissal of the prior indictment
to be with one with prejudice must be
made on his time
subject to his investigation and in his
prosecutorial discretion
and for these reasons we ask that all
the claims against
the commonwealth's attorney in the
planner's first amendment complaint be
dismissed and the commonwealth attorney
no longer
be a party to this action okay so brian
that seemed pretty
aspirational for an argument from a
defendant in a civil case
about wrongful arrests basically i could
almost hear the trumpets of
righteousness sounding in the background
do you think the prosecutor is really
doing the right thing in this case
do i think they're doing the right thing
if i open up a legal book and look at
what the steps they could and could not
have taken probably but
i think from a moral standpoint there is
some error there but unfortunately i
think the prosecutor is right when
you're measuring the harm that occurred
here after the fact i'm not talking
about having brianna taylor die in his
arms
talking about the prosecution after the
fact it's going to be very hard for
kenneth walker to point out damages
when they drop the case let's move on
now attorneys for kenneth walker said he
was injured when he was arrested and
charged the first time
and that the law allows them to sue to
recover for the past harm and
prevent any future harm the defendant's
arguments overlook the fact that mr
walker already has been
harmed he already was improperly
arrested
and indicted the fact that that mr
walker might
again be arrested and indicted in the
future the fact that that is
as it was characterized a near
hypothetical because it might not happen
is exactly what the declaratory judgment
act is designed to
address and that again is pretty simple
it is injury that is either
actual or imminent that has been caused
by the defendant
and that can be redressed by something
the court can do
the u.s supreme court has made clear
that the plaintiff can file a
declaratory judgment action before the
harm occurs
the defendant's arguments ignore that mr
walker has already been harmed he's
already been arrested
and indicted in the past and just those
actions alone are enough to support
standing
the judge questioned whether he had to
let the ag's office off the hook in this
case but
not the prosecutor who filed the charges
the defense countered that the ag could
take over the case at any moment in
charge walker yet again in the future
and that walker needed to sue the ag
right now to prevent that so
terry i say this case should not be
thrown out it seems clear to me
under kentucky's stand your ground law
that walker was harmed
when he was charged when he was
practicing self-defense
aaron i could not agree with you more i
reviewed walker's complaint in great
detail and it alleges
he had the right to stand his ground and
he did he was in the right place and he
had a gun and he was being attacked and
he wasn't committing a crime
and he also alleges in his complaint
these tort claims like you
mentioned the malicious prosecution and
the abusive process
and he definitely has been injured he
suffered
you know they treat him like a criminal
so he definitely suffered some trauma
and humiliation
i think he has a right for that kentucky
law protects against that now keep in
mind detective hankinson
is also facing other legal trouble apart
from the kenneth walker civil suit
and apart from his ongoing criminal
indictment related to the brianna taylor
case
a woman is suing hankinson for what she
says is a 2018 sexual assault
the plaintiff who was a law student says
it happened after hankinson gave her a
lift home from a bar where he was
working security
she says she fell asleep intoxicated and
that she awoke to hankinson assaulting
her
she says she tried to get him to stop
and says hankinson tried to later
suggest
the whole thing was consensual police
have made an arrest in a hit-and-run
crash that killed a prominent defense
attorney in cincinnati ohio
angelette leafy has details about the
person who's now behind bars
the man charged in the crash that killed
attorney steve adams turned himself into
police in cincinnati
a judge set his bail at 500 thousand
dollars cash
this is his booking photo he's 22 years
old and his name is brandon marksberry
he lives a short distance from where
that crash happened on november 1st
he faces a felony charge marx berry is
accused of hitting adams as he rode his
bike early that morning
and then taking off a woman who lives
nearby heard the crash
and comforted adams as the ambulance
arrived
i just sat out there with them until the
ambulance came i he
the kid talked to the ambulance i sat
there and talked
to his name's stephen but i talked to
stephen and just could tap down and hold
on you know the ambulance was coming
um he wasn't talking but he was moving
his eyes and
um his head but he was uh
he was he was bleeding he had his helmet
on he had full gear biking gear and
stuff like that so
but he wasn't um i mean he wasn't able
to move until he heard the ambulance and
he tried to
roll over and get up right now
marksberry faces that one felony charge
but there could be additional charges
added
when the case goes to the grand jury for
law and crime daily i'm anginette levy
and still ahead on law and crime daily a
new trial date for the so-called
doomsday husband and wife charged in the
idaho
disappearance of two children and later
on
could two men be let out of jail despite
charges they shot and killed a black man
while he was jogging
long prime daily returns with that case
in just a moment
[Music]
welcome back everybody the so-called
doomsday called couple lori valo and
chad day bell have a new trial date
the husband and wife are facing two
felony charges related to the
disappearance of valo's children
the bodies of seventeen-year-old tylie
ryan and seven-year-old j.j
valo turned up on chad dabell's property
the husband and wife were scheduled to
be tried together in march but
the date has now been pushed back to
next july
a bond hearing to determine whether two
of the three defendants charged with
murdering ahmad arbury in georgia
can go free before trial this hearing
involves gregory and travis mcmichael
the father and son accused in the case
prosecutors say gregory mcmichael
started chasing arbury as he left a
construction site
son travis mcmichael is accused of
firing the shots
they both claim self-defense the state
says the defendants could pose a danger
to society and
cites racist text messages between the
men and their friends
do you recall that text exchange between
you and defendant travis mcmichael
in which he was talking about shooting a
black coon with gold teeth
that had a high point 45 he was
referring to a raccoon
okay a raccoon with gold teeth in
high point 45 it was being facetious
to which he responded that this raccoon
needed newport cigarettes is that
is that your testimony
the defense says this case isn't about
race and the defendants don't pose a
potential flight risk
despite an ongoing department of justice
investigation into potential hate crimes
we believe this murder case here in
glenn county
is defensible and winnable i look at
that hate crimes case if the feds ever
do
bring one as eminently defensible and
winnable
in order to address the court's concern
that we might pose a risk
a significant risk of flight if released
on bond
in this murder case because we have some
fear
that the feds are going to come arrest
us and charge us in federal court with a
federal hate crime
where i am even more confident that that
case could be beaten
based on the statutes that i'm familiar
with
based on the types of cases in these
press releases that they do prosecute
they're really meant to illustrate this
is what federal hate crimes cases are
really about
in this case is not one of those
okay brian so four different friends of
the mcmichaels the defendants offered to
put up their
homes for the purposes of bond but one
of the friends also said travis
mcmichael developed the skills to go
completely
off the radar as a hunter so talk about
a mixed message from the friends
yeah that's not what you want to tell a
judge when the prime
question is whether or not this person
is a flight risk if you have the skills
to
literally fall off the map and not be
found that's something that's going to
give the judge some pause regardless of
how many homes
are going to be put up as collateral
exactly so now terry
something else we've got to get out of
the way here when we talk about bail
reform we're generally not talking about
this type of offense
alleged well that's right most of the
time when you're talking about bail
reform like in new york or new jersey
we're talking about eliminating cash
bail for low-level misdemeanors
and non-violent crimes so here you know
you see
obviously that the defendants have been
charged with
felony murder and you know assault and
obviously these are
not the type of crimes that we're
talking about and you know one of the
reasons why we have bail reform
is to make sure that we don't have this
two-tier system
advantaging those with money and
disadvantaging those without money so
this is not one of those cases
exactly we're talking about much lower
level offenses and as brian pointed out
usually the point of bail is to ensure
someone returns to court not punished
but as the friend testified here
that may still be an issue and when we
return here on law on crime daily
death penalty arguments in the case of a
pro baseball player accused of triple
murder
using his own bat plus a massachusetts
woman is believed to be her state's
first exoneree based largely on racist
emails written against her by the
prosecutor's office which sent her to
prison for 17 years
we'll look into that case after the
[Music]
break
[Music]
now to the story of a massachusetts
woman tried not once not twice but
three times for murder in a deadly fire
which killed her parents
the first two cases resulted in hung
juries a conviction finally stuck
until appeals lawyers uncovered a series
of racist emails from the prosecutor's
office
which tried the case against the
defendant francis choi
i spoke recently about the case with
reporter deborah becker from wbur radio
i had heard about the case a while ago
and it heard about the email
uh a while ago because they actually
came to light in a different case
and this was in a dispute within the
plymouth county district attorney's
office the office that prosecuted france
and there were mentions of racist emails
on the part of prosecutors
then a defense attorney for francis joy
wanted to see these emails and to see
if these racist emails were referring to
his client francis
and it took him years to get them so it
really was uh the work of a very dogged
criminal defense attorney that brought
all of this to life
it was a five-year process as i
understand it to even get those emails
why did it take so long
well uh there was a lot of stonewalling
quite frankly on the part of the d.a
saying we're not sure what exactly you
want with these emails we don't know
which ones you're talking about
it went to the state's highest court and
the court ruled
you have to turn over all emails what do
the emails actually say
um the emails are really disturbing uh
they're
very disparaging um against asian
americans
against the defendant in this case and
her family
they make a lot of mocking references
and make fun of the trial
we thought really i mean were
prosecutors
really writing something like this uh
it it was mind-boggling the prosecutor's
office has apparently promised reforms
did those reforms go far
enough and have they been implemented
well it's hard to know
if they've gone far enough um they they
say
again pointing to this case they say
that
uh that they are showing that they take
this very seriously
and they will not allow racism to affect
their work
uh so uh and they will not allow racism
within the ranks of their prosecutor the
people that actually wrote the emails or
out of that office now that's my
understanding correct
they are they are and uh they one of
them
uh is a prosecutor in another county in
massachusetts do you believe this
defendant is factually innocent
certainly the government here did a good
job improving this case and there were
just
way too many factors to bring this
forward again i think that
there are too many questions about the
evidence the testimony of a key witness
uh and and then these racist emails on
top of it
i don't see how they could have gone
forward people are
outraged by it and um
you know i think there's a lot of
sadness that someone
lost 17 years of her life and those 17
years during that time
she's proven to do some exemplary things
in prison uh you know getting an
education and taking
all kinds of programs better herself
francis choi the exoneree said in a
statement that she hopes her life
outside prison will honor her parents
who died in that fire
her conviction was based on a shaky bit
of testimony from
a nephew who changed his story to claim
francis choi
made him write notes about how to set
the deadly fire and when we come back
here on law on prime daily
life or death for a former pro baseball
player that's the question
his defense claims he's mentally ill and
should not be executed
a former pro baseball player is now
facing a possible death sentence after a
jury convicted him for committing three
murders
brandon willie martin was found guilty
of slugging to death with a baseball bat
his
own father his own uncle and a security
system installation man
the jury must now decide whether martin
should be locked up in prison for the
rest of his life or whether he should be
executed
terry austin picks up the case from
there erin a psychologist testified for
the defense that she began treating
martin in 2012
and diagnosed him with paranoid
schizophrenia she saw him again in 2014
after his baseball team fired him
and what did brandon tell you that day
you
and my mother are trying to dope me
up so i will not play baseball
again i don't need to be here so he's
basically accusing you and his mom of
trying to
medicate him so he can't play baseball
again is that correct
correct that that phrase that you wrote
there is that fall in line with your
diagnosis of paranoia and schizophrenia
yes he was
clearly parent weight even against me
that i'm trying to hurt him
not to help him and again
you put the severity level at high
correct yes the risk level
high correct yes
the psychologist prescribed abilify for
martin and created a psychotherapy plan
on cross she told prosecutors she saw no
suicide or homicidal tendencies
i have people talking in my mind right
but those people i mean those people
could be
uh jiminy cricket sitting on his
shoulder telling him
uh to do good for all you know right
yes we can only assume but could have
been at the same time a
demon telling him to kill people and he
didn't detail about that
right but you would expect that would be
a
important piece of information if it was
known if it was a no
if it was known or if it was known
yesterday
so yes if mr martin or mrs martin said
you know what brandon was going around
saying that these demons were telling
him to like hurt animals
you would expect that would come out in
this yes right but probably they didn't
hear him saying this thing right
psychologist and law and crime expert dr
john dalatory says
the notes from martin's psychologists
indicate martin needed
more mental health care he seems to be
deteriorating
but there's no clear reason as to what
exactly is going on
so just because someone is complaining
that they're using
that someone's prescribing them drugs
doesn't necessarily make it a delusion
it's probably true that he's not able to
compete at a high level because of the
drugs that he's taking
but what makes it a delusion is he
saying that
they're purposefully dosing him with
things and
that's the problem because then he
should be in a higher level of care
not continuing to see an outpatient
psychiatrist
so terry so many accusations of
substandard care here how does the jury
take that all in and weigh whether or
not
this man should be sent to the death
chamber
well you know he clearly has some mental
illness we heard testimony from the
psychologist
we heard testimony from his brother
about his behavior so
i think the jury is going to take that
into consideration
and i think they will probably agree
with dr deletori and say
he needed more help and he should not
spend
the rest of his life in a jail and he
should not be put to death
he needs to be in a mental institution
with some mental care
brian do you agree with that assessment
absolutely and sometimes when you have
trials like this the jury wants to find
the bad person as a defense attorney
far too many times ask your client but
here it seems the defense has the
ability to kind of shuffle that away
to say this is the bad person and my
client is actually a victim in one way
shape or form
so if the jury is able to find some
sympathy and say he didn't get the care
he deserved then maybe that sympathy
will mean
it's a life sentence but they did find
him guilty so that stage of the case of
course is done
thank you so much for joining us here on
law and crime daily we very much
appreciate it
we'll see you next time as we discuss
these and other cases there's a lot to
talk about
when it comes to justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you